so when you i want to go back now to the
pixies so when you
were with charles how did lovering
what's his name
dave lovering that's what i said you did
love herring yeah he's a magician right
yes so dave lovering
he's the drummer of the pixies and how
did kim deal how did that happen
yeah we took an ad out on the uh paper
uh the uh boston phoenix at the time wow
yeah like wanted bassist
and drummer yeah it's like uh we we
asked
charles asked you know wanted female
bassist influences huskerdu and peter
paul mary
that's it
huskardu and peter paul and mary
yeah wow we're weeding them out yeah
also we had one one one response
that was it that was kim kim and and we
we loved there instantly
wow yeah and then how did dave lovren
get in
dave lovering was um
he went to their wedding
kim deals and his uh and john's
wedding um john
worked with david at radio shack
wow yeah and and he goes like how won't
you have him come in
he came in played the drum machine a bit
left
and uh you know and then we
tried out one other guy we played with
him and he just he was just
so he was late tardied sometimes didn't
show up
ah and uh i said what about dave
you know yeah yeah and he goes ah he
didn't see me and i just said
he was just he just he was high as a
kite you know
i knew it and and uh and we called him
he was excited about i knew he had the
ch
he had the chops i mean he was just
playing these drum machines patterns
like wow oh my god wow that dude's got
it i mean he's
you know because drummers are like uh
back then were trained with
just pads you know random queues and all
this stuff
and now you know most of them just go
right on the kit
right you know but you got to know your
uh it's interesting that you said i
think
a lot of it has to do with probably you
know
being disciplined enough to practice and
get together you need reliable people
that's what i feel like that you had
that with
we did we had a good work ethic yeah
yeah because there's no
because you you guys rose pretty you
were young you rose pretty quickly no
yeah yeah yeah yeah that you know
21 you know we still we played
our first gig i don't think i was even
old enough to uh
get into the club yet i we had to
pretend
yeah i wasn't 21 yet was it original
music you guys were doing at the club
yeah it was wow it was it was
uh 20 minutes or something yeah first
so then oh you guys practice right and
then you know i mean you're you're
collecting
original music because i don't know how
i i don't know how it works i don't know
how
well tell tell joey about your band
experience and
your tardiness and how you essentially
got kicked off
the band i was in a band called
laxton superb what
yeah a laxton superb is an apple
okay right so we were a psychedelic band
right it was four kids just in high
school
right and then what happened was
we played at this coffee shop called the
metaphor cafe
in escondido california this is probably
in nineteen ninety
three yeah psych band
yeah and there was these two
hippies that also played at the metaphor
cafe and they were like
maybe 20 or 30 years older than us but
they were so good
that the lead singer of my band asked
these two old [ __ ] to be in my
our band and then it was now it looked
like [ __ ] the grateful dead it was
like
you know six [ __ ] people up there and
then they had me in the very back
right and i was just like what am i
doing back here so
i just said i don't want i think his
name was dave
i forgot who the other guy's name was
and i go i don't want them in the band
they go well they're good and and
they're in the band so there's nothing
you can do about it
so then in protest i just stopped
showing up
to rehearsals thinking that that was
gonna
you know that they're gonna be like oh
bobby's not around so we'll kick them
out and get bobby back in
but then they all had meet us at
metaphor cafe at 3 p.m
so i show up and then they go um
you're out where did you play
we played like pool hall no no what
where's your instrument a keyboard
keyboard yeah i can play the keyboard
okay
a pretty good keyboard you know it's not
like professional like you joey
no no no you don't have it's not [ __ ]
professional but you know i mean i did
what i could
and um but i wasn't that good so um
they kicked me out and you know what i'm
i'm grateful
i'm [ __ ] grateful and thank you for
kicking me out because without that
without that [ __ ] genki i would have
never done comedy because that's when i
started going oh you know what i got to
figure something else out so i started
doing improv classes
right and showing up at the improv
comedy club in pacific beach
and hanging out what are those guys
doing now yeah one of them works for
[ __ ] cheesecake factory he designs
the the walls oh that's cool yeah
there's nothing wrong with that that's
pretty good
cool that's pretty wait the cheesecake
factory is notorious for cool walls
yeah that's what they're like known for
they're known for their cool wall more
than no but the little lines on the
walls
yeah more than cheesecake sometimes is
that what it is
i swear to you like there's this whole
like there's a
there's this whole like thing about the
cheesecake factory art
oh so he's doing well he's doing well
and then i guess he's doing better than
i am
so then the other guy allen he lives in
san diego and
he he's an accountant that's good too
yeah
that's pretty good gotta keep the books
going man that's pretty [ __ ] good
that's good you gotta keep the books
going all right well then i got f i
[ __ ] i got [ __ ] by kicking out of
the getting kicked out of the band yeah
and i'm sorry to them and i feel remorse
why'd you kick me out so anyway so let's
go back to
the [ __ ] guest my friend here
so what was the so when did you what was
the show that like turned into like
oh [ __ ] we're gonna make it
oh you know
it might have been the first